so Warren Buffett everybody loves Warren
Buffett everybody was invest in
Berkshire Hathaway and all his companies
well it now sounds like he made kinda be
getting into the marijuana game so
Berkshire Hathaway owns a company called
cubic designs which is a unit of
Berkshire's my tech business and these
guys basically they make these things
that make floor space in warehouses more
functional and more usable and they have
been giving ab giveaway flyers about a
thousand fliers uh to weed dispensaries
in recent weeks because it basically is
a way that they can maximize their floor
space so we've got an image of the flyer
so this is what they're giving away and
they're showing to these companies that
this is how you'll maximize your growing
space and you'll be able to grow a lot
more weed now of course weed is still
illegal under federal law we've got a
couple states that have it medicinally
and recreationally I think we weave to
recreationally we got Colorado and
Washington is that I think that's right
those are the big too um but this you
know all the stories we've done on weed
in the last year on marijuana I keep
saying we just once starbucks is in the
game or once warren buffett's in the
game that's the game changer and is this
it is this it now you're not in with you
already ah beware Marlboros swipe at
marijuana because they'll probably load
it with all the same chemicals and crap
that addicted that isn't just tobacco
and the cigarette you have to look for
whatever the American spirit version of
the marijuana cigarette will be and read
on the side no gmos I mean this whole
world of food with the GMOs and all the
chemicals and biochem agric em it's like
a picnic and wherever you move it the
bugs find out they go there no matter
where you are on the lawn and
the larger issue is to start cutting
back on the use of these toxic things to
make everything grow and without that I
will not trust a large companies version
of any of that anything there any chance
in that but isn't that the way the whole
freaking system works i just watched
food I just don't yeah well not the
whole solar system is actually changing
right now it's inverting the opposite
direction the world is marching on the
GMO movement even if we're the last to
get it because we're put under like we
are hypnosis of victims who think we're
a chicken in a nightclub somewhere we
have no idea how under we are about how
crappy our food is and the corporate
junk that they're feeding our kids that
are rising autism and all this other
stuff and people so if that's going to
make its way into the every other new
thing that comes on the market which
assuredly will I think we have to have a
greater awareness than hitting the
separate whack Amole issues and hitting
the main thing on the head stop making
all of this stuff so that doesn't even
make it to that yeah I just watched food
inc a couple days yeah right you know we
talked about the stuff on the show a lot
but it goes to all the things you're
talking about and if you guys really
want to watch something that'll that'll
explain why the the food system is so
screwy and why could in fact even the
marijuana system but you took it to the
to the depressing place first because I
my original thought was wake up we yeah
my original thought was a Warren
Buffett's gonna get in on it and then
we'll get sort of these companies that
will hopefully do this and it'll that'll
push the legalization effort but
ultimately it goes in that yeah be aware
of it and I said I don't stop it from
happening while it's happening work on
this other thing and to some degree it's
a mislead to say he's getting in on the
marijuana business he's selling loft
space well but he's a businessman yes
what he's he says he sees a new business
that can use a product that he has
access to and he's saying let me just
market this to those guys it's not as
though he's investing heavily in
marijuana growth he's saying hey you
should buy some of my stuff to help you
grow marijuana it's a very different
kind of thing so that's sort of the most
American thing you can possibly do right
like he's I thought the most American
thing you could possibly do was move
into someone else's house and then give
them any smallpox infested blanket so
that they go away
but I'm sure he has another subsidiary
that's doing that but I didn't I don't
know Adam our language cuz I'm holding
up what we call a firearm yeah I goes
boom do you guys have hope that we'll
have a little bit before it gets to the
the big companies do you think we'll
have like a couple years where really
cuz right now most of our weed has grown
somewhere probably in northern cali or
wherever they're getting from where it
is by or a lot of organic farmers and
all that kind of stuff before the
company's really get in and muck
everything's up you think we're gonna
have like a couple years of the Golden
Age of marijuana maybe we're in it right
now I don't know could be I mean it's
not federally legal and they're still
buying giant rolling things in every
city to roll in and crush the marijuana
place with a battering ram tine haze on
the road yeah where the weed grows as
high as an elephant's eye yeah um yeah I
think that we might be in right now the
boom of the economy of Washington's
economy is really like leaping ahead I
think that will register to other states
is their education their roads are fixed
things using a pair infrastructure
should they be on board this the weed
thing that's what I'm always amazed
about they want you know the tax read
out that right now you think they owe
their figuring this out the Libertarians
should we listen to those libertarians
will anger the questions can we trick
the Christians into wanting it we don't
know what to do we've tricked them too
much they don't trust us inhale it makes
a burning gosh tell the colorful Bernie
with junior no that's the Old Testament
oh [ __ ] we're trying to Chris Christians
up these guys smoke a lot of pot so
that's what just happened
you